can you maybe comment on what is
nihilism and is it at all a useful
other sort of group of ideas that you
resist against in defining
existentialism yes good excellent so
nihilism the the philosopher who made
the term popular although it was used
before him is nietzsche nietzsche's
writing in the end of the 19th century
in
various places where he he published
things but largely in his unpublished
works he
identifies the condition of the modern
world as nihilistic
and
that's
a descriptive claim he's looking around
him trying to figure out what it's like
to be us now
and
he says it's a lot different from what
it was like to be
human in 1300 or in the 5th century bce
in 1300
like what people
believed what they the way they lived
their lives
was in the
understanding that to be human was to be
created in the image and likeness of god
that's the way they understood
themselves and also to be created sinful
because of you know adam and eve's
transgression in the garden of eden
and to have the project of trying to
understand how as a sinful being you
could nevertheless live a life a
virtuous life how could you do that and
it had to do with for them getting in
the right relation to god he just says
we we
that doesn't make sense to us anymore in
the end of the 19th century
god is dead says nietzsche famously
and what does that mean well it means
something like
the role that god used to play in our
understanding of ourselves as a culture
isn't a role that that god can play
anymore
and so nietzsche says
the role that god used to play was the
role of grounding our existence he was
what it is in virtue of which we are who
we are
and nietzsche says
the idea that there is a being that
makes us what we are doesn't make sense
anymore that's like atheism so art is
taking that from nature and so the
question is
what does ground our existence and the
answer is knee hill nothing
and so nihilism is the idea that there's
nothing outside of us that grounds our
existence
and then nietzsche asks the question
well what are we supposed to do about
that how do we live
and i i you know
i think nietzsche has a different story
than start about that
nietzsche doesn't say
doesn't emphasize
this notion of radical freedom nietzsche
emphasizes something else
he says
we're artists of life
and artists are interesting
because
the natural way of thinking about
artists is that they're responding to
something
they find themselves in a situation and
they say this is what's going to make
sense of the situation this is what i
have to write
this is the way i have to dance this is
the way i've got to play the music
and nietzsche says we should live like
that there are constraints but like
understanding what they are is
complicated
aspect of of of living itself
and there's a great story i think
from music that maybe
helps to understand this i think
nietzsche of course jazz didn't exist
when nietzsche was writing but i think
nietzsche really think is thinking of
something like jazz improvisation i mean
he he he talks about improvisation
there's classical improvisation
nietzsche was by the way a musician i
mean he was a composer and a pianist
not a great one really
to be fair but but he loved music
and
herbie hancock who's a pianist a jazz
pianist
who played with miles davis for quite a
while in the 60s
tells this kind of incredible story
that i think exemplifies nietzsche's
view
about
the way in which we bear some
responsibility for being creative
and that gives us a certain kind of
freedom
but we don't have the the radical
response the radical freedom that's art
thinks so what's the story herbie
hancock says
they're they're they i think they were
in stuttgart he says
playing at playing a a show and
things were great he says
he's a young pianist and miles davis is
the
master
and he says i'm i'm playing the i'm back
in the
solo and i'm playing these chords
and he says
i played this chord
and
it was the wrong court
[Laughter]
he's like it just like that's what you
got to say it didn't work right there
and i thought holy mackerel i screwed up
you know i screwed up we were tight
everything was working and i blew it for
miles who's doing his solo and he said
miles
uh paused for a moment
and then all of a sudden he went on
in a way that
made my cord right
[Laughter]
and i think that idea that like you
could be an artist who responds to
what's thrown at you
in such a way as to
make it right
by what measure
everyone could hear it is all you can
say right everyone knew wow that really
works
and i think that's not like there are
constraints not anything would have
worked there
he couldn't have just played anything
most of what anyone would have played
would have sounded terrible
but the constraints aren't like
pre-existing they're sort of
what's happening now in the moment for
these listeners and these performers and
i think that's what nietzsche thinks the
right response to nihilism is we're
involved
but we're not radically free to make any
choice and just stand behind it the way
sart thinks our choices have to be
responsive to our situation
and they have to make the situation work
they have to make it right
and there's there's something about
music too so you basically have to make
music
of all the moments of life and there is
something about music why is music so
compelling
and when you listen to it something
about certain kinds of music it connects
with you it doesn't make any sense but
in that same way for nietzsche
you should be a creative force that
creates a musical masterpiece exactly
and i think what's interesting is the
question what does it mean to be a
creative force there there's a
traditional notion of creation
that we associate with with god
god creates ex niello out of nothing
and
you might think that nihilism thinks
that we should do that create ex nihilo
because it's about how there's nothing
at our ground but i think the right way
to read nietzsche is to recognize that
we don't create out of nothing miles
davis wasn't nothing that situation
pre-existed him it was given to him
maybe by accident maybe it was a mistake
whatever but he was responding to that
situation in a way that made it right he
wasn't just creating out of nothing he
was creating out of what was already
there
you